hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
monday the twenty-eighth of april and
you are watching games but news let's
get into it for those holding out it
seems that destiny is definitely not
coming to pc at least for the
foreseeable future the shooter will land
on xbox one ps4 ps3 and xbox 360 on sep
tember 9 but even though the game is
being developed internally on a pc
design leed laws back and says that
doesn't necessarily mean that bungees
upcoming title will be available for
that platform he explains the truth is
it's not that simple i wish it was that
simple it's pretty complicated that
doesn't mean it can't happen in the
future it just means it won't happen
right now when I'm playtesting and I'm
trying to play ps4 xbox one xbox 360 and
ps3 that's a lot of work adding another
thing on there is just crazy a pc
version hasn't been completely ruled out
for the future but since all versions of
the game will connect to a singular
persistent well angie has said that it
creates some challenges xbox live is
getting a slate of original programming
whether you ask for it or not and here's
what you can expect a swath of
interactive programs are coming and
while the phrase interactive TV doesn't
tend to be a popular one xboxes nancy
tellem is promising interactivity will
be organic to the piece she explains to
add interactive features such as adding
that social community and being able to
communicate in real time with others who
were actually watching we're working
right now on time shifted comments
because it's a video on-demand platform
comments that come in about the show
when you watch it'll be as if it's
happening while you watch and you can
participate in them as well so I guess
it's like having a sea of moviegoers in
your living room who won't just shut up
and watch the damn show as for the
program's themselves Microsoft have
geared up their halo TV series with
Steven Spielberg as executive producer
another untitled halo digital feature a
soccer reality TV series and eight
episodes sci-fi drama called humans a
whole bunch of extra room at titles and
presumably something else about halo for
all the
details on what will be landing on the
service you can check out our new story
on gamespot last off the mark today we
have some more news from Bungie who are
promising that they're not favoring
PlayStation over Xbox when it comes to
destiny a fan asked why the Xbox fan
base is being ignored to which bungie
replied who's ignoring you we're right
here making a game we hope you'll love
the outcry has likely come out of the
fact that destiny was showcased at
Sony's ps4 announcement and then again
at the e3 media briefing the destiny
beta will also be available to
PlayStation consoles first destiny will
be bungees first multi-platform game in
a decade let me know if you're excited
for destiny and what platform you'll be
getting it on in that commenting section
down below or if you prefer you can chat
to me directly on my Twitter and those
are all the things I have to tell you
about today but I will be back tomorrow
with a bunch more gaming news unless
Australia invents any more public
holidays I'll see you guys soon